[Musique]
Yo
Oh
[Musique]
à la campagne où l'on vit plus tranquille
pas comme dans les centres avec lesquels il va
ce soin est vrai du tout
Et à la campagne plus personne ne vit
calme et il ne me semble pas qu'il n'en ait pas
de tant de danger
[Musique]
bon
bien à mon âge je me sens bien parce que
il y a de la clarté
le Seigneur me fait marcher
objectif silencieux
peut atteindre peut-être km 4 km
[Musique]
calme la réplique aussi
et qu'ils valaient pour que ceux qui piquaient
crèche de copain
[Musique]
Oh
bon
soit
Oh
[Musique]
a changé la forme du jour
ce n'est pas la même chose qu'avant les gens d'avant
il est tombé il s'est aidé dans l'illuminable
Non
[Musique]